muchos ven las devastadoras inundaciones
de alemania como un llamado de atención
para los políticos que les obligó a
poner el cambio climático en la cima de
sus agendas no solo si asumimos
decididamente la lucha contra el cambio
climático seremos capaces de controlar
situaciones meteorológicas extremas como
la que estamos viviendo ahora
las inundaciones repentinas de esta
semana han dejado un centenar de muertos
cientos de desaparecidos y miles de
evacuados
el 26 de septiembre se celebrarán
elecciones federales y estatales y con
ellas el fin de una era
angela merkel dimitirá tras 16 años como
canciller su posible sucesor es el
político conservador
armin laset jefe de renania del
norte-westfalia una de las regiones más
afectadas por las inundaciones de vida y
más vida media nos enfrentaremos a estos
eventos una y otra vez y esto significa
que necesitamos más velocidad en las
medidas de protección climática a nivel
europeo nacional y mundial
la set ya ha establecido un vínculo
entre el cambio climático y los trágicos
eventos los políticos conservadores ya
se enfrentan a críticas entre tanto los
candidatos opositores a las etts el
socialdemócrata olaf scholz y angelena
bar book del partido verde visitaron las
zonas afectadas sabiendo que el
comportamiento en días de catástrofe
puede ser decisivo el día de las
elecciones